[Music]
I thought I'd start by just reminding you that this talk
combines work in two books - one on the left called "The
Four Steps of the Epiphany", the other one a book that if
you don't have on your shelf you should. It's called "
Business Model Generation" from a guy named Alexander
Osterwalder. And if you're an entrepreneur the book on the
right is almost now a fundamental text - and I say text even
though most people now have kindles. I think there's
probably a good startup to be had to make fake spines for
all the books you now have on your Kindle cause there's no
way to tell when you graduate from Stanford what you
actually have read. So, if anybody's looking for an idea for
a startup. That's a joke. So, I guess in this class I'll
have to tell you when to laugh, so I will.
So, I also write a blog. Anybody ever see it? It's called
SteveBlank.com. How many of you are entrepreneurs or want to
be? So, every possible way to screw up a startup is in here
- most of them done by me. So, if you want some stories on
how I've actually built some companies and then in the blog
I kind of expand to some thoughts about entrepreneurship
since I first wrote the test, "Four Steps to the Epiphany".
So, I want to tell a few short stories today - the first
one, an observation about the democratization of
entrepreneurship. I've been in Silicon Valley now for 33
years. Hard to actually remember back that far, even harder
to admit but in the last 33 years entrepreneurship and its
twin venture capital has changed dramatically but subtly. I
don't think we've even understood how dramatic those changes
are. And I thought I'd spend the first part of this talk
actually going through those changes and then talking about
one of the techniques and one of the pieces in
entrepreneurial education that's been one of the catalysts
of change.
So, I just want to remind you what some of the constraints
are for startups. When entrepreneurs first came to this
valley - '60's, '70's, '80's and even the 1990's - it cost a
lot of money to start a company. How many of you were in
software startups? You know, hopefully a good number of you
in software started with your credit card. But in the old
days if you were in the software business step one was buy
expensive workstations, step two was buy expensive
development tools. It cost millions of dollars even for a
software company to get started pre turn of the century.
Some of this is still true in hardware domains, but it was
also just an implicit fact of every type of startup. It cost
millions to start a company. It took a long time to get to
first customership. Engineering was done using something
called waterfall development. I would spec the product, make
sure it had an entirely long and perfect list of features
making sure I got that list by looking at all of the
competitors features, making sure mine was at least three or
four longer, handing that list to Engineering who would go
off and go implement for something called Version 1
sometimes months, more than likely a year or two from the
day you started.
This waterfall development methodology was about all we knew
until the 1990's. Customers took a long time to adopt. First
customers in Silicon Valley were government subcontractors.
They did not buy in days or weeks. It took months if not
years to get an order.
The next wave of customers in Silicon Valley were companies.
Again, these were long sales cycles and the number of
customers for Silicon Valley companies could have been
measured in hundreds, maybe thousands.
High Startup Failure Rate
For 40 years the implicit notion was that startups were
smaller versions of large companies and that all you did in
a startup in a board meeting - reporting to your Board - was
focus on your execution of the business plan that your VC's
had bought into. "Here's what we're supposed to do. Here's
when we're supposed to ship. Here's the orders we're
supposed to get. Here's the revenue we're supposed to have."
And by the way, there were a limited number of these VC's.
3000 Santo Road there's maybe 20 of them up until about
1975. That was it. They all wore white shoes, looked like
they just came off the boat - nice press pants, all went to
the same school - very small eco system. And not only was it
3000 Santo Road. It was limited to a few regions - 3000
Santo Road, Miguel Park, California. You wanted money? That
was the address.
So, what's happened? What's happened is something kind of
interesting. These were all constraints on eliminating the
number of startups certainly in Silicon Valley. I'll observe
in the last five years almost all of these constraints
certainly for the wave of internet commerce and social
networking companies we've seen have been eliminated all at
once. Let me tell you why.
Startup constraints have been replaced by what I call an
entrepreneurial explosion. Now the cost of getting to a
first product can be developed if you're doing a software
company on inexpensive PC's, Macs, using open source
software. The cost of starting a company is no longer
measured in millions; it's measured in your credit card
limit.
A Short Time for First Product
It no longer takes years to develop a product. Using an
agile methodology - that is a software methodology that
allows you to develop incrementally and
[inaudible] - now says you could get a minimum viable
product or a core part of your product out the door in weeks
if not months or months if not weeks.
Fast Customer Adoption
Our customers are no longer only the government and
corporate. Silicon Valley has now turned to consumer
applications. Who would have ever thought Facebook would
have a half a billion customers! That would have been
science fiction - science fiction! Think about it. A Silicon
Valley company with a half a billion customers in how many
years? Three? Four? Unbelievable!
Lower Startup Failure Rate
Startups until the last five or 10 years have been in hit or
miss proposition. We talked about the people, we talked
about having great board members, but we really didn't
understand the first line. Big insight in the last couple of
years is no, startups are not smaller versions of large
companies. Probably if you take in anything from this talk,
that's it. Everything you are - and how many of you are in
Stanford GSB - in the Business School? Great! Everything you
learn in the Business School about large company management
is destructive for an early stage venture. Big idea.
It's not kind of useful or "gee, I'll just change it". What
you'll hear later and I'll explain why - it's destructive.
Good news is in the entrepreneurial group at GSB we teach
the right things about early stage ventures, but they are
not interchangeable. And you'll hear me say this throughout
this talk. Large corporations execute existing business
models. Startups search for them. The tools needed,
techniques needed, the people needed for execution vs.
search is what we now know to be radically different.
Understanding those rules is what the rest of this talk will
be about.
But let me just finish the circle. We now have a much larger
pool of risk capital just in Silicon Valley. I couldn't even
put all the names on here. There's been an explosion in the
last 20 years and even more so in the last five or 10 of a
pool of available capital. Seed Rounds, Super Angels -
larger pools of venture capital all have kind of exploded.
And venture capital and entrepreneurship is limited to
technology clusters like Silicon Valley. We can now easily
say it's just as easy to start a company that's in Miguel
Park as it is in San Francisco, New York, Shanghai, Israel,
Chile, Singapore, Finland, etc. while still the highest
concentration of technology innovation in the U.S. is here
because basically we're a company town meaning our cluster
does nothing but this. There are multiple clusters that are
forming in other cities. So, this talk is going to be about
one of those pieces of the explosion, about what we now know
about how to lower startup failure rate and that's the
purpose of the talk.
The next story about that starts with this notion that not
all startups are equal. Now, I've been in Silicon Valley for
more decades than I care to remember or are actually
possible to remember by now. But one of the things that
surprised me teaching at Stanford was going into a classroom
of some other professor and hearing them talk about
entrepreneurship and who an entrepreneur was. And with the
shock of me not recognizing who they were describing because
it turns out if you get three professors in the room to try
to define startups and entrepreneurship, you'll get nine
definitions including I throw four of them in myself.
It dawned on me that we really lack the common language of "
Who's an entrepreneur? What's a startup?" Even more
important now that our government has decided to get
involved with entrepreneurship and startups. In fact, I tend
to panic hearing that the Labor Department is going to have
an occupational code for entrepreneur. We should all figure
that it's about time that entrepreneurship has jumped the
shark.
But I want to give you my definition of the types of
entrepreneurs there are. You know, there are small
businesses in the United States that are entrepreneurial. My
parents came to the United States as immigrants in
[inaudible] bottom of a boat. Passed under the Statue of
Liberty, came through Ellis Island, lived on the lower east
side of New York, and their dream was to open their own
grocery store. That was their dream, American Dream - be
self - employed, not work in the garment district, you know,
be able to do what they wanted to do.
Ten years later they managed to scrimp and save enough money
that they did. And their job was to serve known customers
with a known product and feed the family. And their exit
criteria for them being a startup was they were finding a
business model. Their business model consisted of
understanding the types of foods their customers wanted,
stocking them, and figuring out how to price them. And they
did it with an existing team - my mother and father, and
then when we were old enough to see over the pickle barrel
it was us. And if they made $1 million in their entire
lifetime would have been a lot of money.
But I believe - and still believe - that my parents were
entrepreneurs. And they did do a startup, but their goals
were very different from what we consider startups in
Silicon Valley. Their goal of a startup was to be self -
employed, not have anybody tell them what to do, and they
did not wake up in the morning thinking they were going to
take over the grocery business in the United States. Their
vision was limited and they were happy to be limited.
But at the same time, there was no way they were going to be
able to go to a venture capitalist - even if one existed at
the time - and raise money. Money came from bank loans,
friends and family, whatever they could save out of profit.
So, I just want to observe that small business startups are
still the core of what America does. There are 5.7 million
small businesses in the United States today. It's 99.7% of
all registered companies. It employs 50% of all non -
governmental workers are in small business startups.
Now what's funny, in Silicon Valley we have a term for these
people. We call them lifestyle businesses. And some of you
are like, "Yeah! I'll be in the lifestyle business." Right?
They could be people who are consultants, people who run
their own, you known, grocery store, hairdresser,
carpenters, farmers, small groups of plumbers, all are
lifestyle businesses. You know what the real name for these
people are? Normal. Right?
Those of you sitting in this room are the ones who are crazy
because what these people want to do is live a life and then
go out - if they have some spare time - and actually enjoy
it. Their goal is not to work 24/7 though some of them get
trapped in doing that. But their goal is not to take over
the universe or anything else, but they are entrepreneurs.
I will observe that there's another group of entrepreneurs
and startups. And we also - if we're Silicon Valley
entrepreneurs - we tend to diss these people too. It's
entrepreneurship in large corporations. Fifteen years ago a
professor at Harvard named Clayton Christianson really
nailed this definition. Christianson said, "Look, there are
two types of innovation in a large corporation. One is
sustaining innovation. That is large companies start with a
core product and as they mature they start spinning out
innovations around that core - new features, different
pricing, add on's, supplementary products - and large
companies as a whole tend to be good at this. Sustaining
innovation deals with existing products and known customers
with known product features.
But large companies have a finite life because of things
that happen mostly out of their control - competitors
emerge, new technologies show up, customer tastes change,
legislative or legal changes - all the sudden large
companies are faced with disruptive innovation. And
disruptive innovation requires them to come up with new
products, new technology, deal with new customers, new
markets and new channels.
The best example closest to home is Google, the world's
leader in search. They were going to own the planet forever
until somebody raised the pirate flag in Palo Alto - a bunch
of guys called Facebook. Holy cow! Google which was the
world's leader in your interaction with a browser literally
in a span of three years found a competitor growing up in a
domain which may have absolutely no expertise. Google is
facing disruptive innovation and will do anything they need
to do because they're a smart and innovative company
including acquire IP, technology, product, companies, etc.
So, go deal with this threat.
But I just want to point out that inside of large companies
there are groups that are equivalent to startups today who
are searching for a business model, not executing one. By
the way, the way you deal with disruptive innovation in a
large company is 1) you try to build it.
That is "Ah great! There is Facebook. We'll build Facebook
inside. Look how big we are. We can do that." And I don't
know if any of you ever wondered, but I always wondered, "
How come large companies get tripped by the underwear at
their ankles every time they try to compete?" They've got
like a gazillion resources! How come they can't compete with
scrappy little startups? And the answer is Shakespearean and
it's tragic. And we'll be talking about this in the rest of
the talk.
Large companies - once they get to a certain size - hire
people to execute known business models. They manage those
people on profitability and success in executing the model
they were hired for. Large corporations don't hire
generically innovative people and I don't mean they don't
have innovative people.
I'll give you an example - McDonald's. Anyone want to admit
ever walking into a McDonald's? Okay. Good. Alright.
McDonald's in Des Moines, Iowa and McDonald's in Miguel
Park, California believe it or not have essentially the same
menu.
Imagine one day the Miguel Park McDonald's hires an out of
work entrepreneur as the manager by accident - it's going to
happen one day - who wakes up and says, "This menu's boring.
You know, we ought to be serving pizza." The next morning
there's a line almost rioting outside the McDonald's because
you can't get your Big Mac anymore.
The point is McDonald's doesn't want innovators in the
majority of its execution change. Somewhere back in Illinois
I'm sure they have a lab of testing innovative ideas, but
99.7% of employees in a large corporation are hired to
execute an existing business model which makes trying to do
disruptive innovation internally 10 x or 100 x harder, not
cause people are stupid in large corporations - far from it!
But they were actually hired to go do one thing and their
incentive to do one thing. And here are these crazy people
in the offices next door to them trying to say, "We're not
filling out the expense reports in triplicate. We're
entrepreneurs!" Just culture clash all the time.
So, large companies tend to acquire - not always, but often
- they acquire intellectual property. They might acquire
talent, head count - which is by the way why Google acquired
50 companies last year, most of it for people. They inquire
product lines, or they acquire for customers, or they
inquire for entire businesses and P & L's - various reasons
why companies acquire.
So, I just want to point out so far we have two types of
innovators, two types of startups - small business, large
companies. But that's not what Silicon Valley is about.
Silicon Valley is about this - a third group which I call
not startups, but scalable startups just for the sake of
making the point that you do a startup in Silicon Valley, it
is not "I want to grow from 1 - 5 people." It's "I want to
do something substantive. I want to change something. I want
to build something important." And typically the goal is to
solve for unknown customers and unknown features. And you
start as a startup on the left, but your goal is to find a
business model, and to grow into a large market, and to grow
into a large company.
Startups search for repeatable and scalable business models.
Your goal is to go from the box on the left to be a box on
the right - a company that could execute. A scalable startup
is designed to grow big and what differentiates it as well
from a small business in a large corporation is that it
typically needs risk capital - venture capital. By the way,
anybody know what venture capital used to be called?
In the 1950's when they came up with the name they said, "Oh
yeah! Why don't we call it 'Adventure Capital'?" And the
bankers in New York said, "No". And they said, "Okay. We'll
shorten it." So, Venture Capital. But when Silicon Valley
says startup what we're really talking about is not small
business startups and not large corporation startups. Does
this make sense?
Why it's really important is why we sit here in Silicon
Valley we all think we kind of know what the word needs. You
step out of this bubble, go to Washington, D.C. and try to
talk to legislature or the executive branch. Go to
Sacramento. Go to Nebraska. People have no idea what this
is. They know what small business entrepreneurship is.
Making sure we use the right words and also as an educator
making sure we educate correctly - Outside of the United
States this is the unknown. Outside of the U.S. small
business entrepreneurship is what people think entrepreneurs
do.
So, here's my definition of what a Silicon Valley startups
is - which by the way, just help me understand what is it
we're supposed to be doing? My definition is that a startup'
s is a temporary organization used to search for a scalable
and repeatable business model. That's a big mouthful, but
pretty important. One is a temporary organization.
My belief? There's no such thing as a 12 year old startup.
There's a two year old startup attached to a 10 year old
failure. Big idea because your job in a startup is to
search. If you knew exactly how to execute you just would
hire the first 150 people as quick as you can. You actually
are looking for something and what you're looking for is a
repeatable and scalable business model. The words "
repeatable" and "scalable" should make sense, but the words
"business model" I will also define as we get further into
this talk. Make sense so far?
So by the way, have any of you been in startups? Yeah. So,
there's a secret memo none of you have ever gotten. Any of
you venture capitalists? No one's going to admit it. Okay.
There's a secret VC memo because instead of this diagram you
go from startup to large company. VC's actually know it
doesn't work like that. You go from startup to transition to
a large company.
I always thought, "Gee! Okay! I get it! I leave being a
startup when I find a scalable, repeatable business model
and when I do that, my expectation was at the board meeting
at the minimum they were going to pin a medal on my shirt,
give me a handshake - maybe a gold watch - and parade me,
you know, up and down the aisles of the company with
confetti saying, "Congratulations".
Instead, you know what happens to most entrepreneurs when
they find a scalable, repeatable model? Board meeting kind
of goes like this. The VC's for the first time - first time
- VC's who didn't even know your name are now paying
attention to you. I don't know if all you know, but a
typical Silicon Valley PC sits on anywhere from 8 - 12
boards, right? So, when they're physically showing up at
your board meeting they physically have to get out their
Blackberry, or Android phone, or iPhone and look up your
name, right? Then they're looking at the sign on the
building to figure out they're at the right company. You see
one VC. They see 12 CEO's in a month.
And by the way, when you're talking about your board meeting
"Blah. Blah. Blah. Blah. Blah. Blah. Blah. Blah. Searching
blah. Blah. Blah." You know what? They're kind of listening.
They might be on their phone, but the board meeting when you
say, "And we think we've cracked the code and we have some
repeatable revenue where users" or something - all the
sudden you've got that VC's attention because for the first
time you're no longer a faceless mass in his portfolio. But
all the sudden, you're an important company that might
actually provide a substantive return in that VC's return.
All the sudden, the VC is now looking at you in a way that's
making you kind of uncomfortable because they're looking at
you up, and down, and through the side. And what they're
actually thinking is, "Okay. You got me out of the box on
the left. But are you the person capable of taking me to the
box on the right?"
You did great flying around the country. You did great, you
know, doing one thing on Tuesday, the next on Wednesday, and
something different, and hiring and firing, or whatever. But
gee, you've just told me we no longer need to do that. What
you've just told me is we've gone from search where we're
doing different things every day to repeatable where we need
to execute. Now, my question is as the VC is are you the guy
or the woman? Interesting question.
So, there's really a box in the middle called the transition
and what the VC's don't tell you is you're going from
search, to build, to execute. And what happens in this build
phase is most often then not the founders depart. And that's
a very polite way of saying you're holding onto the
doorframe and the VC's are pushing you out because most
first timers - even often second or third time CEO's - don't
quite understand it's not personal. But right here your
interest and your VC's interest which were aligned are now
diverged because VC's have a different business model than
you and their career objective is different than you. It
isn't personal, it's business.
And the business part is - what venture capitalists want to
see - is somebody capable of bringing in scale that is
growing your startup to a large company. Are you as the
founder capable of doing that? And more often than not, they
bring in what's majorly called "the suit" but truly is an
operator - somebody who's an operating executive who is
actually skilled at doing this. Make sense so far? Anybody
ever encounter this? This is why. It's a secret memo you
never get and it's nothing personal.
The bad news is - and I laugh about this with my friends who
are VC's - how come you don't tell founders this? And they
go, "Steve, so imagine I'd be the only VC telling you, 'Hey,
by the way, when you succeed I'm going to replace you.' Do
you think I'd ever get another deal?" And so, this is kind
of the secret. And it actually does injustice to
entrepreneurs not understanding this is a normal part of the
process.
The interesting conundrum is think about who runs today the
most successful technology companies in the world - Steve
Jobs, Lori Allison, Jeff Bezos, at least for the first
couple of decades Bill Gates. I'll contend they're the
exceptions to prove the rule. And by the way, remember Jobs
had to get fired by an operating executive he brought in to
go understand this. There's a growth process that most
founders don't actually go through fast enough. World class
founders actually figure out how to quickly - almost like a
chameleon - adapt and learn a set of skills that most of us
take multiple companies to go do.
By the way, anybody know how many presidents Bill Gates went
through at Microsoft? I think it was at least five and he
learned from every one of them - every one of them. That
make sense? Just keep that in mind. By the way - as an aside
- as I said, if you fail you stay a startup.
So, one of the things I thought I'd share is my startups
aren't small versions of a large company. And this really is
an interesting thing to process cause when I started in the
Silicon Valley I said, "Oh yeah! I know what we do! We do
everything that we used to do in our large company. We'll do
it here in our startup." So, I'll suggest that that's very
different. I'll suggest that's wrong. That in a startup -
the box on the left - we're searching for a business model
and it needs to be found by the founders.
Now, we're looking for product/market fit and we're looking
for a repeatable sales market, and finally, when we exit the
startup phase we can start hiring managers. But in a large
company you're executing and you become a large company when
you kind of hit cash flow, you break even, and you're
profitable, and you're hitting a rapid scale, and you're
hiring new senior management. That's something called
Dunbar's Rule. About 150 people, that's another major
organizational shift.
Anybody know why 150 people become a company? Anybody know
Dunbar's Rule? It turns out that human beings can't remember
more than 150 people. It's not exactly that number, but plus
or minus. You're just as a human being. We're hard wired for
that number. You've become a company and when you've become
a company, your drive for profitability is hiring people who
know how to do the same thing cause you've already figured
out what that successful model is.
Let me give you another difference. Large corporations run
on balance sheets, cash flows, and income statements.
Anybody in the GSB taking an accounting class? Is it a
required class? Right. If you're running a company and you
don't know how to do corporate accounting you're going to
put the company out of business I don't care what department
you're in. You need to know that. It's the very basis of how
we manage and grow companies.
Anybody ever been in a startup board meeting? Now, I've got
to tell you I was in startup board meetings for eight
startups, 20 years. First board meeting, "Alright what do we
do?" "What we do is we show them balance sheet, income
statement, cash flow." "Okay. Great. What's the income
statement say month zero - month one?" "Zero." "What's it
say month two?" "Zero." "Month three?" "Zero."
But not only am I paying somebody to prepare all these
documents, we actually think that the Board is actually
managing something by looking at these numbers here on the
left. I'll contend from now on if any board does that in a
startup, you walk out of the room. The only thing you need
to know about numbers in a startup in the early days - day
one - that has to do with dollars is, "How much cash do you
have left and what rate are you burning it at until you hit
the ground?"
There are other numbers that you need to know that are much
more important that you want your board engaged with and
that's the metrics associated with you trying to search for
a business model. Here happens to be some for an internet
startup. Your own will be different. But the key idea is you
want your board engaged in helping you figure out, "What
numbers should we be looking at?" They ain't accounting
numbers! You should be so lucky to have this problem as how
to count the amount of cash we have or the amount of money
that's coming in the door. And maybe you're the rare startup
that actually needs to do that on day one.
Most startups are trying to find a business model and you
really want your board engaged in a much different
conversation. "Are we looking at the right metrics?" "Are we
going after the right people?" "Should we be measuring
something else?" Make sense?
Sales
Anybody ever see a large corporate VP of Sales? Not large,
but I mean a VP of Sales from a large corporation? Anybody
ever see one? Huh? What do they look like? How tall are
they? Yeah, six feet or more. What color is their hair,
Scott? Right, a little bit of gray. And what's their golf
handicap? Single digits.
Large corporation VP of Sales and we laugh about that? Those
are actually good skills to have. Those are actually good
characteristics to have. They're also not stupid. They're
actually pretty smart, but they almost look in the United
States like a type because they're world - class at building
sales organizations, making those organizations scalable,
and having sales forces that could sell off our price lists,
and data sheets, and they operate brilliantly to an existing
revenue plan. That's what a world - class VP of Sales does.
And when you do a startup, my dream was always, "Hey! I'll
just hire one of those people and if I can't get one of
those people I'll hire one of their directors and tell them
they can be a VP in my startup." "Hey look! They did great
over there!"
I have to tell you my last startup, I hired a world - class
VP of Sales early from Oracle and I still remember the day.
We'd just got thrown out of our fourth company we'd called
on in a row. It's pouring rain - kind of like a day like
this but worse - and you know, I'm shell shocked as the
founder. But I've got this great VP of Sales and he's
driving. And he's about to start the car and I go, "Where
are we going?" He said, "Well, we've got another call." I
said, "Gee! Another call? We just got thrown out four times
in a row!" I said, "Don't we want to stop and think about
what we've learned?" He said, "Steve, great sales people
just never take no, you know? They just keep going."
And by the way, that's correct only when you actually
understand a known model. When you don't know what the model
is that's destructive behavior. And in fact, those people -
world - class sales people - actually melt down in startups
because this guy in our next week started freaking out when
I said, "Well, this presentation isn't working. I'm going to
make up a new one." And I was making it up on the drive to
the customer. He goes, "You can't do that! I know what the
existing pitch is!" "Jay, the existing pitch isn't working."
"Well yes, but that's the one we have." "Well, I'm the
founder. We can make up a new one."
Smoke would come out of his ears and it wasn't because he
was done. It was actually because he was great at what we
had hired him for and it was our mistake for not
understanding the following:
Titles on the right actually don't mean the same thing on
the left. I'm sorry? I'm not sure I can, but I will try.
Titles - VP of Sales, VP of Marketing, VP of Bus Dev - well
understood in a company that's executed. Gee, VP of Sales in
a large corporation - hire the sales force, make the revenue
plan. Hey! Execute the model, sell off the data sheet and
price list, right? That's what a VP is. Takes whatever spec
you want in a large corporation. That's pretty close.
In a startup, in the first year or two that's not what the
job is. "Oh my God! What is the job?" "Well, I don't know.
We're going to go get out of the building and figure it out.
Data sheet, price list, website - we're going to change them
until we get them right. If you don't have people capable of
operating in chaos on the left, it explains why most of
these people meltdown when they hit a startup because even
though we use the same title, the job descriptions if we're
actually honest are quite different. Does that make sense
now?
Engineering same thing. Large corporation - great VP of
Engineering to take a market requirements document, put it
together in a waterfall development plan, hire engineers and
then at the end have a QA and Tech
[inaudible]. I can always now tell when a startup is in
trouble because the first thing I ask is in the first year
or two, "So, how many people do you have in QA and Tech
[inaudible]." And if the answer is more than one it's a
disaster because in a startup in almost every case you need
to be doing a very different type of engineer. Waterfall in
a large development says, "I spec the product, and I
execute, and you'll get it at the end."
In a startup, except for corner cases you really don't know
what to spec. And what you want to do is agile development,
incremental and
[inaudible] development. That requires much different
engineering leadership and talent. So, we'll talk a little
bit later about the types of startups.
There is a type of startup that's executing in an existing
market. An existing market by my definition simply says, "
You have a product which is substantively better as agreed
to by the existing customers in that market and you are
going to take market share from the incumbent. If that's the
product you have, then you could spec the entire product on
day one. That's the corner case. Most any other type of
product that's not the case. You're searching for what the
right feature set should be. Does that make sense? And in
fact, it's detailed in the book, "Four Steps of the
Epiphany". I'm not trying to flog the book, but just FYI.
Actual development, continuous deployment, continuous
learning, self - organizing teams and you're going to shift
not the maximum feature set - which is the goal in a large
company, but the minimum feature set or sometimes called the
minimum viable product - big idea. In a startup, you want to
get to market as quick as possible, but not by offering
every possible feature, by doing the exact opposite.
Boy! That's really a hard concept. I want to offer the
minimum features on day 1. Whoever thought you could offer a
smart phone without copy and paste? Anybody remember which
smart phone that was? iPhone. Or who could ever offer a
music player without an FM tuner? Anybody remember what that
device was? iPod. Minimum feature setting, right, will
incrementally add features later as needed. But first we
want to get the product out and see if our core idea is
correct.
Last piece - especially for those of you in business school
- large corporations love business plans. Business plans are
wonderful in a large corporation. I know who the customers
are, I know who the market is, I'm doing a product line
extension, I could spec everything and it describes a set of
knowns. A business plan in a startup is a creative writing
exercise. A business plan in a university I will contend is
only done because it's easy to grade, not because it
provides students any use at all. It's actually detrimental
to your career. In a startup instead of a business plan, you
want to spend your time working on a business model. And I
will describe later what a business model is. But it
describes unknowns and sets you up for what you have to
learn.
So as an aside, how do startups search for a business model?
Well, the search is something called customer development.
Here I've blown up that box at startup and the
implementation is called agile development. And I'm going to
talk a little bit more about customer development.
After 40 years I think we understand why startups fail
because more startups fail from a lack of customers than
from a failure of product development. Now, this is a
mindblower in Silicon Valley. This goes across any
technology except for biotech. We'll leave biotech aside.
But hardware, software, Silicon - we take more technology
risks here in Silicon Valley per square foot than any other
place in the world. And you would think companies go out of
business cause engineering screws it up.
The reality is in most companies - in most markets - 90 -
99% of the failures are from a lack of customers. Now, for
those of you who are engineers don't feel smug because I've
never seen a product delivered on time. But it's not like
the company goes out of business because of that. It goes
out of business because of this.
So, I find it very interesting that for the last 40 years
Silicon Valley has had tons of processes to manage product
development, but no processes to mange customer development
- none. And in fact, the only thing we used to have is this
product introduction model. Anybody ever see this before?
You know,
[inaudible] product development, alpha tests, beta tests,
first customership. Anybody ever see this? Come on. Yep?
In fact, when I used to put this up in my class students
would say, "Yeah. Yeah." You know, "We've seen this." And I
used to say, "Yeah. Even the waiters in San Francisco could
draw this." And some of them used to say, "Well, we're
waiters because we used to be dot com CEO's." And they said
that so that I'd never make that joke again. So, I won't.
But startups fail because of this diagram. This diagram says
[inaudible] and convinces founders to make two major
mistakes. One is, "I know what customers need and because I
know what customers need, I could spec the product on day
one. Right there." Now, this is pretty interesting because
startups are an act of faith, right? They are driven by the
passion of an entrepreneur. And so, part of your passion has
to be a believe that you actually do know what problem to
solve.
So, this is a real conundrum and the way I describe it is
that on day one a startup is a faith - based exercise. Truly
it's a passion. But the startups that survive very quickly
replace that faith with facts as quickly as possible. And
that is instead of executing completely on faith while I
know it's my vision, they go, "I know it's my vision and I'm
scared out of my whatever that I might be wrong." And so,
here's the process to check it out. And that's what we're
going to talk about.
But first, I'm going to remind you how startups used to
work. You'd draw this diagram in your board meeting, the
board would node sagely yes and then you'd say, "Well, here'
s my marketing plan about what I was going to do in what
order. I'd create markup material, hire a PR agency, have it
create demand, have a launch event". They'd nod and "Here's
how I was going to hire my sales VP. I was going to hire a
sales VP from a large company, build a sales organization in
time for first customership, and then I'd hire the all
important bus dev person, and then I'll hire engineering
from day one. Maybe my co - founder will do all this stuff."
This is how you go at a business. I think it's pretty well
understood that what boards used to tell you was, "Yeah. You
got it. Good. That's our plan." Now, it's actually the
leading cause of death of a startup. Why? Because you really
don't find out whether you're right or wrong all the way
until you've burned cash, hired a ton of people and launched
the product. So, in contrast here's how startups succeed.
They do something called customer development and this is
where the founders get out of the building.
Customer development says, "Instead of this product
introduction model, we're going to replace it with something
else. We're going to tell Engineering to go do agile
development, but we're going to create a process for
managing facts and that's a four step process. And that's
called customer development."
* This first step - customer discovery - gets you out of the
building to test every hypothesis you have.
* Customer validation ensures your hypotheses are correct by
actually getting users or orders that validate your
solution.
* Customer creation is where we scale the business.
* And company building is that stage where I had labeled
transition before - remember, where you get to leave? Maybe
you don't get to leave anymore. You get to stay.
And so, let's go through a bit of it.
* Customer discovery says, "Listen, instead of writing a
business plan, let's write down all the hypotheses. By the
way, I use the hypotheses because does anybody know what
current tuition is at GSB? What's current tuition? How much
is it a year? $50,000, right?
If I were just to say, "Test your business model guesses"
you'd feel cheated, right? But since you're paying $50,000 a
year inside a business school I use very expensive words,
right? So, you can tell your parents, "I got my money's
worth." But if you really think about what's going on in a
startup implicitly unless you're a domain expert - another
corner case - as a founder, you're actually guess. You're
guessing and you're guessing about a lot of things or maybe
you're guessing about a small set of them, but you're
guessing.
In customer discovery, we're going to say, "Guess what?
That's a normal part of startups. But we're going to make
you write them down, and get out of the building, and start
discovering whether they're true or not as quickly as
possible in a formal process. And you're not allowed to
outsource this. Why? Well, what if in fact you were a
founder?
You're a founder. Ready? Okay. Got a great product, your
vision, and you hired a VP of Sales early on. And she comes
back and says - what's your name? Nate? Nathan? Nate?
Alright. Nate, let's be formal here. "Nathan, I'm your VP of
Sales. You know, I got out early. I'm talking to these
customers. You know what they say? The product sucks." What
are you going to tell me? I'm your VP of Sales. Find better
customers. Great!
So, she comes back again after a month. "You know, I've
flown all around the U.S. and I don't know how to say this.
They think it really sucks." What do you say?
[inaudible]. Right! And there may be a step in between that
says, "You're just not explaining it correctly", right? Or "
They just don't get it", right?
And then you do exactly what Nathan said. You fire the VP of
Sales. Is it going to get any better? But how come the CEO
didn't say, "Well, maybe that's true." What's going on?
What's going on? Why wouldn't you say, "Perhaps that's true"
. Why? Why would you ignore facts? You think you're scared?
[inaudible]
Alright. It's an emotional investment whose consequence -
yes?
[inaudible]. Sometimes. Sometimes it's even worse than ego.
By worse I mean you're so blind to your investment in not
only time, money, but the idea that there's a cognizant
dissidence that occurs. And by the way, this is a big idea.
It will occur to every one of you in a startup. This is not
anybody being stupid. This is human nature at work here.
The only way to break this chain is the founders need to go
out of the building. So Nathan, we're going to pick on you
some more. You're still the CEO. You're out of the building
and I'm a customer. And you ask me, "What do you think of
the product? Ask me."
Nathan: What do you think of the product?
"It sucks."
[inaudible]. "It still sucks, Nathan." What do you do now?
You got to the next customer because you go, "Obviously
they're an idiot. They're not deserving of my product."
Right?
Now, I would rather draw this out. It takes most people
three times to hear it before smoke starts coming out of
their own ears. By the way, it usually takes me about five
or six times to hear it. But I'm going to say most people
will never get it the first time. I guarantee you 99% of
people won't get it the second time. It's kind of a bell
curve. I was on the bleeding edge. In fact, what's worse is
the greater your reality distortion field personally, the
harder it is for you to listen. Big idea.
By the way, if anybody's thinking of doing customer
development, don't do it if it ain't you or your co -
founders getting out of the building. It can't be outsourced
because you will be hearing things that are counter to your
instincts, beliefs and whatever that you need to process.
And eventually you will process them if you're hearing them.
"I will guarantee you, you will ignore them if brought to
you second and third hand." That's why hiring consultants to
go do this, etc. - consultants can make intros for you and
help you organize the process, but you personally need to be
hearing that data.
By the way - Yes?
[inaudible]
Yep.
Yeah. Go read the blog. There's a ton of it there - a ton.
And there are lots of people that are writing about this
now, but yes. And in fact, at the end I'll point you to some
resources.
[inaudible].
Yeah. There's a tab on the blog called "Startup Tools" and
it links to the sites tools on how to build technically a
startup. There's a ton of links to other blogs that talk
about it.
By the way, our old friend the business plan sometimes rears
its head here going, "Well, shouldn't I be just executing
off my plan?" I'm just going to say this one more time. No
business plan survives first contact with customers.
Business plans come from large companies. They are great in
large companies. They're great for professors who consult
for large companies in business schools. Seriously. No
professor I will contend to actually did a startup can look
you in the eye and tell you this is a useful document. And
because we never had anything to replace it with, you know,
there was no other contest to run. But I'll show you we
actually need to be looking for a business model.
As I said earlier, if you put four professors in a room
historically you'd come up with nine definitions of what a
business model is cause everybody through that word around
like it meant something. Now, for the first time I'm going
to show you what it means because of the work that I showed
you in this other book in the beginning, Alexander
Osterwalder.
Osterwalder had a great insight. He said any company could
be described in nine building blocks. And I'll give you the
cliff notes of the book in a second. He said, "Listen, first
building block is 'Who are your customers? What users are
they serving? What jobs do they want to get done? What's
your value proposition that you're giving them?" That's a
fancy word for "What product or service are you building?"
How are you getting it to them? Is it the web? Direct sales
force? Indirect channel? And how are you creating demand?
What kind of customer relationships will you have? And by
the way, you add all this stuff up - what's your revenue
model? Don't tell me free. If it's free it has to be a two
sided market meaning, "Okay. It's free and finish the
sentence. And then we will make money by, you know,
whatever. And it could be, "Well, we'll figure it out later.
" "Alright. Well, that's just at least a declaration of
faith. It's not actually a business model, but we could at
least have that conversation."
On the other side is, "What key resources do you need?" If
it's a software company you need great engineers getting
scarcer in Silicon Valley. If it's a hardware company do you
need to go offshore? What do you need to do to perform it
well? Is it manufacturing? Is it something else? Do you need
any partners? iTunes - Without the record labels iPod would
just have been another piece of hardware. Partners in some
businesses are essential. And by the way, when you add up
all the stuff on the left what's the cost structure? Nine
building blocks can describe any startup now. Osterwalder's
thing was a stroke of genius.
And you can now take those and put it into a canvass that
is, you know, we just took that fancy, nice drawing and
said, "Hey! Let's just make this a canvass." And now, we'll
take all our hypotheses. Remember those hypotheses I talked
about? Your business is made up of a set of hypotheses? Let'
s take the hypotheses about your product! Who's your
product? What's the market type? What's your competition?
Customers - what type of problem do you think they have?
Who's the customer? Who's the user? Who's the payer? Who's
the saboteur? Who's the influencer? What type of channel?
And you add all these up and you can now use the Osterwalder
business model diagram to actually become a score card for
customer discovery.
Remember I said, "Get out of the building?" Now you can
actually say, "How are we doing on this?" Hey, wait a
minute! Our first assumption of who the customer is? Oh,
that was wrong! Customer is actually over here. Well, wait a
minute. Our pricing model we thought it was a premium
business, now it should be a subscription business. Boom! We
can change that. It's just a nice, visual way to show us
over time what we're learning.
The goal for engineering during this time is to build what's
called the minimum viable product. Minimum viable product is
the smallest feature set that gets you something and you get
to define what that something is. Is it the minimum feature
set that gets me orders or is it the minimum feature set
that just gets me learning? I want to put up just a red
button on my webpage to see if I can get anybody to push it.
Truly, that could be a minimum viable product for week one
in a startup. "Can I create demand to get people to this
page?" or it could be, "No, I know what the core features of
our website should be and are offering." Great! Do those. Or
is it to get feedback? Or is it to test some failure modes?
The first two things you need to be testing in that
Osterwalder diagram is the minimal viable product and who
that customer is. But remember, it's just one of those nine
parts of that business model. And you're doing this customer
discovery and validation, and again keeping score with the
Osterwalder diagram.
Now, there's an arrow on the bottom called the pivot. This
is actually the heart of customer development and it's
actually what we got wrong for the last 40 years of
startups. Remember I kept saying, "Startups are not smaller
versions of large companies"? Well, we never acted like that
and here's an example why because any of you that have ever
been in a startup are going to recognize this scenario.
Startup goes through a launch first customership, has a
great board meeting, everybody's high fiving each other
because Tekron heard about your company, you know, people
are hitting the website, things are wonderful.
Next board meeting,
[inaudible] VP of Sales. How's the number? - Referring to
the revenue plan. VP of Sales says, "Oh! That sales pipeline
is great." What does that mean? A website could be, "Well,
we got lots of clicks, but it didn't quite convert
[inaudible] could be, "You know, we got lots of people to
talk to us, but we're not quite getting any orders."
Next board meeting, "How we doing?" VP of Sales goes, "
Pipeline." Next board meeting, "How we doing?" "Pipeline."
And by the way, the next board meeting the VC's unbeknownst
to you go to school to learn how to cock their heads at a 15
degree angle and arch one eyebrow. I mean, it's just amazing
because they do it, you know, in whatever that word is, but
all together at the same time and they stare at the CEO. "
Really? Revenue plan."
The next board meeting you open the door and I don't know
how they do it, but there's a flaming sword of death over
the VP of Sales and no one is sitting next to her. I mean,
all the chairs are on one side of the room and she knows
that the wrong thing to say. And you shut the door very
quickly because you open it again and she's gone. It's just
amazing. It's like a magic trick. It happens all the time.
And by the way, next board meeting you open the door again
and there's someone else. Just looks like her, but it was a
guy. You know, you're like, "What happened?" "We got a new
VP of Sales."
Now, the interesting part here - some of you might recognize
this story - is that the new VP of Sales unless that guy and
the CEO are complete idiots - does not execute the same
sales strategy as the last one. They go, "Gee! That was
stupid! And it was just because they were idiots! We're
going to do another strategy!" What happens if that new
strategy doesn't work? Who gets fired next? No, not the CEO.
It must be a marketing problem. None of you are laughing,
but yeah. It has to be a marketing problem. And then we fire
the CEO.
What did I just describe here? What I just described here is
as some of you might recognize the normal path on how we
solve problems in a startup. And no one in 40 years
recognized, "Wait a minute! This occurs more often than the
case that we actually execute the plan pristinely." In fact,
in almost every startup it doesn't occur or it doesn't roll
out per the plan. This is a huge idea. Startups are all
about chaos and things not working like you believe. Your
hypotheses are almost always wrong in a startup. That is
they're not often right, yet the way we used to deal with
this is by firing executives to iterate the strategy. Whoa!
What a waste in time and money.
This feedback loop - the pivot - simply says, "Being wrong
is a normal part of the startup. Getting your hypotheses
wrong is normal. So, what we're going to do is instead of
firing people we're going to say, 'You know, we got
something wrong in our discovery process. We just misheard
what the market said because we thought they said if we
delivered x they'd pay y. Don't work that way. Okay. We
didn't hire 15 people on a sales force. We haven't hired,
you know, 100 other people in support. Let's just go
iterate." That's what the pivots for. Make sense?
So wrap up -
Startups are not small versions of large companies.
Traditional big planning tools fail. And startups are built
on hypotheses. You need to test each one of them. Business
models help you keep score. Customer development is the
process to test the hypotheses.
Now, I've got about 11 more minutes. Can I tell you one more
short story? You sure? Anybody wants to leave you can. But
there's one more story of why startups aren't run by
accountants. Anybody an accountant here? I don't want to
complain. You can leave now.
Anybody know who the inventor of the modern corporation is?
Look at this guy. Doesn't he look serious? This is actually
a real Time magazine cover from the 1920's. Anybody know who
he is? Who was he? Yeah. I'm glad you can read. Who was he?
What about General Motors? Who was he?
[inaudible]
Good.
[inaudible]. Anybody else? Yeah. That's what most people
think of him. Alfred P. Sloan, General Motors President &
Chairman - he actually invented the cost accounting system
for running large corporations. Corporations in the 20th
century are basically possible because this guy took the
accounting system that DuPont used in World War I - who was
on his board as you'll hear later - and actually applied it
into making GM a large distributor organization. Put the
managerial and financial controls - and it was copied by
every other major corporation in the United States pre -
World War II and post - World War II led to the American
Century in terms of corporate expansion overseas. Truly a
genius. Lots of things are named after him - MIT Sloan
School, Sloan Foundation, Sloan-Kettering Cancer Institute
in New York.
Everybody know who Kettering was? Oh. Another fact, he was
his VP of Engineering, of course, so great guy. And in some
classes I have people say, "Why yes! He was the founder of
GM." Turns out Sloan had nothing to do with the founding of
GM by 20 years. This guy was the founder. Doesn't he look
like a founder? Come on! Which guy would you rather hang out
with? This guy, you know, or this guy. This guy we can take
in the streets of Palo Alto one night. "Hey! Come on! We're
going on a barge!"
This was Billy Durant. Billy Durant was the founder of
General Motors. Billy Durant also was the leader in the
United States in horse drawn buggies in the 1890's out of
Flint, Michigan. Built the largest horse drawn buggy company
in the U.S. One day Billy Durant was in the bar in Flint
with his fellow buggy manufacturers. Probably Friday
afternoon, knocking a couple back and all of a sudden they
hear this noise coming up this dirt covered street. It's
like the loudest thing they've ever heard. And all of a
sudden they see this carriage coming at them. It wasn't even
one of Durant's. It was one of his competitors and it didn't
have any horses. And somebody had strapped a one cylinder
engine to it - 1890's - and basically, you know, called it
transportation.
And the rest of his friends were hysterical because this
thing looked like it was going to catch fire anytime. Horses
were running wild, you know? And they were all, "Hey Billy!
Look at that!" Durant sobered up in about 30 seconds. Next
Monday he sold his entire business - got out of the buggy
business - and started buying technology companies of the
time - highest tech companies of the 1890's, automobile
companies. He was not a technologist, but this guy was an
entrepreneur.
And Billy Durant bought up a series of car companies and
starts a company called General Motors, builds it into the
largest automobile company in the United States in 1910 and
then is fired by his board because he's a crazy
entrepreneur, insane, careless, reckless, etc. But he's also
pissed. He's so angry at his board for firing him he says, "
Screw you guys", finds another entrepreneur and starts
another car company called Chevrolet. Builds Chevrolet into
a bigger brand and company than General Motors, takes it
public, and buys out all the GM stock, fires his board and
takes over his company again.
Remember a guy named Steve Jobs? Runs his company for
another 10 years in 1921. GM is $3.6 billion in today's
daughters being run by his company's founder and he screws
up again financially. This time he's gambling with the
company stock. I mean, clearly crazy entrepreneur. And this
time the financiers he has on the board aren't some local
yokels. It is the DuPont's and they fire him for the second
time.
Durant gets fired from General Motors in 1921. The company
is $3.6 billion - Durant vs. Sloan. Sloan becomes the icon
of American management - rightly so because from the 1920's
- 1950's the American Century truly is the GM century. He
dies rich, honored and famous.
Durant? He dies penniless managing a bowling alley in 1947.
He was the accountant. You are here. Thank you very much.
So, I've got time if anybody has any questions about God
knows what I said, but any questions? Yes?
[Informal talk]